My name is Hamad Al Magbal, I'm head of the
website development programs at Udacity.
Website development programs aim to teach the basics for programming languages
through which we can develop websites.
By taking this course you'll learn the basics
of programming languages using Python
one of easiest and most common programming
languages.
After that you'll start a project oriented
programming that
will set you in advanced fields in programming
development.
Soon after you'll learn GIT technology which
is one of the technologies that is used for
the developments in the tech and programming
communities
so that you'll be able to participate in this
community and fully able to benefit from it.
After you finish this course you'll manage
to solve problems
using available programs and apply it onto
websites.
After finishing this course you'll have the
required skills that
the tech.
Community demands and those needed by big
companies
like Google, Facebook, Netflix, etc.
In the end I encourage you to enroll in this
program whatever your technical ability is
in order to develop your skills in problem
solving using programming tools
to develop your field and your society.